on va cueillir yacine moyens si l'ua
tard pour son débrief ces particules on
sait que c'est que l'intro ya six ans
qui vit depuis j'adore la soeur bébé
docteur guy non tu le vois de profil que
les moins de vingt ans ne peuvent pas
connaître michel sam
m6 a cependant affiché loana tous les
soirs en direct
la semaine dernière le sujet numéro un
de la télévision française c'étaient les
20 ans de love story
d'ailleurs cyril tu m'as dit que tu
voulais refaire un loft avec les
chroniqueurs de tpm paix et balances ton
post
oui j'adorerais g80 tôt j'avais pensé à
faire ça et malheureusement il ya eu les
restrictions sanitaires donc on peut pas
le faire mais c'est un truc qui me
trotte dans la tête je suis sûr que ce
sera 40 ans 70 jours là où les enfermer
tout le monde rit 70 jours et bien sûr
je serai là je veux pas qu'un ce ton
délire frères ils sont déjà tous
enfermés 6 24
[Applaudissements]
ça entraîne d'imagés ya fait un régime
le seul mec qui a payé pour faire le
ramadan présentée par benjamin castaldi
donc on a pris ça regardez sommes avec
vous et xxi des contres avant de rentrer
dans la maison dans le loft
oui dans lequel vous deviez cd écoutez
bien c'est très 70% de tous vos
bénéfices wilkie sous les habits d'un
tel contrat va pas vu donc vous taxez
les foules c'est un cd à la prod
l'intégralité par quasiment sonné pour
cent de tout ce que vous rapportez oui
londres où l'image de l'émission vous
avez vous fait dire ça c'est un scandale
à l'époque taxés à 70% elle mélenchon
l'a dit c'est chaud voici le classement
après impôts des gens les moins bien
payés dans l'histoire de la télé
troisième rang par les deux chroniqueurs
de tpm p 19 euros 2e rocco le chien de
bernard montiel dans vidéo gag un os à
moelle d'une valeur de 13 euros
les premiers les candidats de loft story
c'est trop la télé réalité en battant
beaucoup de choses ont changé en battant
le en 20 ans le front national il ya 20
ans par dont le front national était
deuxième auto la présidentielle
dorénavant il va même passé le troisième
tour en vain en a tout connu en télé
réalité des émissions de haut vol comme
ligne de la tentation away
[Musique]
souhaitez-vous repartir ensemble ou
séparés
[Musique]
alors maintenant ça s'appelle instagram
j'ai une théorie j'ai dit je suis
persuadé que pour des raisons
économiques
l'hymne de la colonne de la tentation et
koh lanta c'était sur la même île sauf
que les mecs étaient pas au courant et
je suis sûr qu'un jour il ya un mec qui
s'est perdue de koh lanta et qui
revenait qui a dit denis brogniart
excuse moi mais de l'autre côté de ligne
à des steaks hachés des meufs et de la
musique
3 il ya eu aussi le bachelor ah oui oui
oui alors pardon juste c'était une photo
ça mais qui avait décollé de la
tentation des bateleurs l'île de la
tentation c'est notre société le
bachelor pas du tout mec qui avait
quatre femmes dans une villa alors ça
existe déjà dans d'autres pays ça
s'appelle un rêve d'ailleurs l'émission
n'a pas été reconduite en france sachez
le à cause de la loi contre le
séparatisme
après il ya eu le même principe avec une
femme et quinze mecs marjolaine et les
millionnaires voilà way l'envisagé pas
non pas du tout marché en afghanistan
ils n'ont pas du tout aimé le procès
qu'on est secret story qui s'en souvient
ahmed jeune david dont le secret était
j'ai eu 780 conquêtes dans ma vie le mec
avait 25 ans donc soit tu as été
victimes de pédophilie la télé réalité
et comme le covin tous les ans on a
droit invariants ils sont force des gens
télé réalité ce qu'ils ont réussi à me
faire croire que c'est moi qui suis has
been
parce que j'ai pas 2 millions de
followers parce que j'ai pas les cheveux
rouges désolé steevy parce que je sais
conjuguer le verbe être alors moi des
influenceurs c'est de gaulle s'est
regardé les mecs on a même un avant
après le 2 stv
les eaux refluent en sort c'est de
gaulle l'appel de l'ong c'est pas un mec
qui appelle de dubaï en dix ans les gens
ils croivent c'est quand même fou que ça
s'appelle comme ça parce que y'a rien de
réel dans ces émissions qui dans la vie
réelle a construit une carrière en
couchant dans une piscine sur sa
personne et devient millionnaire en
disant à l'eau il ya plus de shampooing
à l'eau qui dans la vie réelle se balade
dans le monde avec 12 marseillais
l'entraîneur de l'om qui a tâché que
dans la vie réelle plusieurs lieux de
culte ont été attaquées ces derniers
temps notamment la mosquée de rennes que
je salue et qu'on salue tous ici une
télé réalité mais une réalité dont la
télé ne parle pas assez
bonne soirée à tous
[Applaudissements]